Coolio man oh yeah certainly oh hey I
gotta go yeah Terry out there are you
doing man hey pretty good Gabe Oh
got something on your shirt not today
Terry
it's like Gabe's come out to play
you do have something on your shirt no I
don't yeah you kind of do look pretty
sure I don't got a clean shirt at my
desk you told me to get it for you don't
see why that would be necessary because
the streets you have on right now it's
not clean except for that it is me I
have a clean shirt oh you you have some
schmutz on your channel it's at my
jammy-jam you know what why don't I just
get it for you yeah why don't you do
that and there we go I'm thinking damn
you good mm-hmm
you know what the funny thing is what's
that now I guess from when I dabbed your
shirt with the paper towel and I'm not
playing the game right now
but I actually I must have got some
paper towel fuzz on your shirt so
[Music]
hey how long has chairman we're gonna
head up like that
[Music]
[Music]
to go through that I'm sorry huh hey
Terry what's going on uh never a good
morning I'm having a terrific morning
great hope there's nothing on my shirt
because I can't look down oh no dude
we're not doing that right now okay
there's nothing on your shirt no one
cares about your shirt everything's not
about you try have a conversation with
Karen right now so
you okay Terry just pisses me off
oh yeah yeah I do have schmutz there
switz all over me now deny that Terry's
not gonna know what hit him
[Music]
what what happened Terry died
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Jerry
it's Gabe I am just wanted to let you
know that um that you didn't get me
Terry you didn't get me because on the
day that you died there was schmutz on
my shirt so guess who wins the game
Terry I do you lose
[Music]
Oh Jerry he flipped me
you